[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
las autoridades de nueva york decidieron
suspender el regreso a clases hasta el
próximo 21 de septiembre con el fin de
incrementar las medidas de contención
contra el cob y 19 la decisión afecta
especialmente a las familias hispanas a
las cuales les urge que sus hijos
regresen al colegio para retomar su vida
laboral
en colombia el profundo malestar social
por la muerte de javier ordóñez bajo
custodia policial derivó en
manifestaciones que terminaron en
disturbios y enfrentamientos con las
fuerzas de seguridad que a su vez
dejaron más vidas perdidas y cientos de
heridos en la capital bogotá
y faltan menos de dos meses para las
elecciones presidenciales en eeuu y a
partir de hoy en aquí américa les
tenemos un segmento especial para
revisar entender y analizar los temas
clave de esta contienda entre donald
trump y yo bailen por la casa blanca
empezamos en nueva york donde más de un
millón de niños estaba a punto de
comenzar las clases el 10 de septiembre
pero tras la presión de los sindicatos y
los profesores el alcalde bill de blasio
retrasó la vuelta al colegio para
implementar más medidas de control
contra el cob y 19 y ahora no será hasta
el 21 de septiembre que los niños se
empiecen a estudiar allí nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala ha hablado con
las familias latinas que esperan con
ansias este nuevo curso escolar
[Música]
alejandra y su marido han tenido que
hacer malabarismos durante esta pandemia
para conciliar trabajo y familia bajo el
mismo techo trabajo de casa lo más que
puedo y con mi esposo nos alternamos en
que si uno tiene que salir el otro día
los chicos
tratamos dolores cómo podemos nosotros
los emigrantes acá no tenemos nuestra
familia que se lo por para la casa de la
tía la casa de mi mamá por eso quiere
que sus pequeños vuelvan a la escuela lo
antes posible de una tela de 5 años
necesita atención especial las 24 horas
del día
y santino de 10 no quiere lidiar con
problemas tecnológicos
siempre tenemos un problema con las
escuelas de online siempre hay un
problema de la conexión o que no anda
eso tienen profesores como young calero
porque estaban en sus casas los padres
asumieron que estaban haciendo mucho y
les presionan a hacer digamos a cocinar
a cuidar a sus hermanitos en ocasiones
no tenían eran varios niños
en una casa con solo un computador o sea
que tenían que priorizar quién iba a
tomar clases algún día situaciones que
viven muchas familias en este barrio del
bronx uno de los más castigados por el
cob y 19 donde más del 50% de la
población es hispana y con bajos
recursos económicos nuestras escuelas
necesitan
y limpieza pero especialmente los baños
donde los niños van a estar utilizando
es esencial que creemos una cultura
nueva de limpieza de los baños en
nuestras escuelas aquí en la ciudad de
nueva york y especialmente en el bronx y
esto es precisamente una de las
principales quejas de los maestros de la
ciudad que las escuelas de nueva york no
están preparadas para abrir sus puertas
además alrededor de 20 centros
educativos necesitan reparaciones en sus
sistemas de ventilación por eso al menos
un 20% de los 8.000 maestros que hay en
esta ciudad ya han dicho que no se
presentarán a las clases alegando que
sufren enfermedades crónicas que les
hacen vulnerables ante la enfermedad del
cob y 19 vamos a colombia la muerte del
abogado javier ordóñez mientras dos
policías lo inmovilizaron y él estaría
repetidamente que se detuvieran desató
la indignación de los ciudadanos en
distintos puntos del país
las protestas en rechazo a este presunto
caso de abuso policial terminaron en
destrozos y enfrentamientos que dejaron
nuevas muertes y que recibieron poca
respuesta de las autoridades
sessa rojas nos cuenta más
en las calles de bogotá se repite una y
otra vez que a javier ordóñez lo mato a
la policía
el abogado de 44 años recibió varios
choques eléctricos con un arma taser
mientras dos oficiales lo reducían en la
madrugada del miércoles 9 de septiembre
la alcaldesa de la capital reconstruyó
lo ocurrido y dijo que lleva meses
denunciando el abuso policial eso es
inaceptable el abuso policial es
inaceptable desde la alcaldía lo hemos
denunciado le hemos pedido al interior
de la policía que es una entidad
nacional que se tomen los días en serio
esa noche estallaron las protestas en
varias ciudades del país el gobierno
respondió así mientras la gente estaba
en las calles
hemos visto hechos dolorosos el día de
hoy pero hemos visto también la actitud
gallarda férrea no solamente de los
comandantes de la policía sino también
del señor ministro de la defensa y de
toda la institucionalidad para que se
hagan las investigaciones a la mañana
siguiente reportaron al menos ocho
personas muertas pero no se explicaron
las circunstancias se sabe que el caso
de ordóñez ir a la justicia penal
militar y el ministerio de defensa
anunció que los dos oficiales
involucrados en su muerte fueron
suspendidos en redes muchas personas
reportaron disparos contra los
manifestantes para el 21 de septiembre
ya se había convocado a un paro nacional
que para muchos es la continuación de
las movilizaciones en contra del
gobierno de ban duque que cerraron el
y empezamos nuestro segmento especial de
aquí américa camino a la casa blanca a
menos de dos meses de que los
estadounidenses decidan quién será el
presidente de los próximos cuatro años
vamos a revisar los temas clave de esta
contienda entre el presidente de donald
trump y el candidato demócrata joe byte
hoy vamos a hablar de un asunto crucial
el estallido social contra los abusos
policiales y el racismo desatado por la
muerte de georg floyd el 25 de mayo a
manos de un policía blanco en mineápolis
y que motivó una revisión profunda de la
discriminación estructural en el país y
llevó a algunos cambios reales como el
retiro de monumentos a líderes
confederados pasando por el mundo del
entretenimiento y el deporte donde por
ejemplo el equipo de fútbol americano
redskins de washington cambiará de
nombre y de lobo en medio de la presión
de los patrocinadores mientras que en el
mundo empresarial la compañía cualquier
retiro el logo de los productos de
aunque mayma tras más de 130 años en el
mercado a reconocer que estaba
en estereotipos raciales
sin embargo los casos de abuso policial
con presuntos motivos faciales siguieron
y siguieron apilándose a lo largo del
año por lo que muchas ciudades
continuaron las protestas y con ellas
los enfrentamientos entre los
manifestantes del movimiento black
lights matters y grupos de extrema
derecha y es que cada vez también es más
frecuente ver en las calles a los
autodenominados vigilantes o justicieros
son grupos armados de extrema derecha
que han sido alentados por el mismo
presidente trump quien abiertamente ha
dicho que es una respuesta legítima al
vandalismo que se registra al margen de
las manifestaciones y ha criticado a los
alcaldes demócratas por no sofocar las
protestas veamos más en el siguiente
informe
en portland salt lake city o que nos a
hombres armados patrullan las calles
pero no están en uniforme estamos aquí
para proteger a los residentes a las
personas inocentes los autodenominados
vigilantes son vistos cada vez más
frecuentemente en las protestas contra
el racismo pero cuál es su objetivo
fuimos a olimpia en el estado de
washington para conocer a peter díaz
fundador de american wolf lobo americano
un grupo de activistas armado errante
ahora no somos sólo una milicia pero
tienen armas sí pero soy estadounidense
y los estadounidenses tienen armas
auditivo llegó a quedarme acostado
mientras mi país es destruido y
desmantelado a mi alrededor los miembros
de este grupo se llaman a sí mismos
guardianes de la paz
díaz creó este grupo a finales de abril
para luchar en contra de las protestas
contra el gobierno que según él eran
lideradas por activistas de extrema
izquierda
ellos quieren alguna especie de gobierno
socialista o comunista así que están
tratando de cambiar lo que es nuestro
gobierno destruyendo nuestro país
viajan por todo el país a veces para
formar contra protestas al movimiento
black light matter armados con lo que
llaman armas de defensa solo esto es una
bola de pintura estándar spray pimienta
un bate de béisbol y lazos para esposar
están en su vehículo this world beat
esto sería para detener a alguien si se
necesita para evitar la violencia de
superbike donde está la policía ha visto
la policía por ahí
también lleva armas letales pongo mi
mano en esta arma no es como si mi mano
esté ya sabes así seguimos a díaz en un
mítin pro trump donde encontramos otra
milicia de extrema derecha cuidando el
lugar se hacen llamar el 3%
uno de los grupos más organizados de
eeuu que le da entrenamiento militar a
sus miembros
y en carolina del sur estuvimos con un
grupo de probar más llamado one republic
mientras el presidente de trump culpa a
los demócratas de los disturbios
los vigilantes parecen estar muy
entusiasmados en tomar el asunto en sus
propias manos
la violencia ponerla en el país
no voy a decir que hay un ganador
queremos paz
weiwei pace pero no le tememos a la
guerra es que era un sondeo reciente
reveló que uno de cada tres electores
estadounidenses cree que su país está al
borde de una guerra civil le mostramos
satrud imágenes de un tiroteo mortal
llevado a cabo por un seguidor de trump
de apenas 17 años que mató a dos
manifestantes en kenosha wisconsin
en mi madre cualquier que pueda ver este
vídeo
puede ver que es en defensa propia de
las milicias armadas no son ilegales en
eeuu donde llevar un arma es un derecho
constitucional y vamos a washington con
nuestra corresponsal diana castañeda
diana quiero empezar por preguntarte
entre los llamados del movimiento black
lives matter está el dif own the police
que consiste en quitarle los fondos a la
policía pero no se puede generalizar y
decir que todos los policías son malos
que representa este movimiento de
desmantelar a los departamentos de
policía y qué consecuencias tendría
hacerlo realmente
exactamente aunque el digamos lema
principal de este movimiento es quitar
estos fondos en verdad lo que busca es
una reforma estructural a la manera como
operan los departamentos de policía a
nivel nacional y que también estos
fondos adicionales que se distribuyen
para estos departamentos puedan ser
utilizados en programas sociales ya sean
de vivienda o de educación sin embargo
este movimiento ha tomado gran
importancia no solamente durante este
año de cara a las elecciones por lo que
representa un debate abierto sobre los
dos candidatos y el apoyo que están
dando ya sean a las minorías como las
personas afroamericanas oa los
departamentos de policía lo que tiene
divididos a muchos votantes en los eeuu
si diana y yo bailan se mantiene
podríamos decir un poco tibio tratando
de hacer equilibrio entre el apoyo que
tiene que seguirle dando a las fuerzas
de seguridad y los llamados que le hacen
desde el ala más izquierdista del
partido demócrata en el que le pide una
reforma policial profunda y esto es algo
que el mismo trump ha usado en su contra
cuáles son específicamente los planes de
byd en respecto a la policía porque no
ha sido muy claro al respecto
si para los dos candidatos es muy
importante tener el respaldo de los
departamentos de policía porque esto se
traduce en votos pero también tener el
apoyo de la comunidad afroamericana y
digamos que esta fue también una de las
razones por las cuales yo bien escogió
como fórmula a harris pero lo que
básicamente plantea el partido demócrata
en cabeza de bailén es hacer una reforma
a los protocolos y procedimientos que
utilizan los departamentos de policía
para realizar estos arrestos y que se dé
un trato justo y digno a las personas
sobre todo que hacen parte de las
minorías cuando se registran estos
incidentes policiales
gracias a nuestra corresponsal diana
castañeda por su intervención desde
washington en este segmento especial de
aquí américa camino a la casa blanca y a
ustedes gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión recuerden que pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas cuídense mucho de el
coronavirus y sigan viendo france24
[Música]
e